the coronavirus stimulus fight heating
up again in washington yesterday
president trump put a dramatic halt to
negotiations
in a tweet telling republicans to wait
until after the election
to cut a deal house speaker nancy pelosi
and democrats quick to attack the
president
over the move on the best of days
the president's thinking isn't too sound
so if there's any impairment
it's a real problem the president has
always had erotic behavior
right now it's very very dangerous that
there are those who say
that a steroids have an impact on
people's thinking
i don't know but there are those
healthcare providers who say that
also if you have the coronavirus it has
an impact as well so the combination is
something
that should be viewed president trump
changing his tune
tweeting and here i'm quoting if i am
sent a standalone bill for stimulus
checks twelve hundred dollars
they will go out to our great people
immediately
i am ready to sign it right now are you
listening
nancy brett bear um despite what the
president said in that tweet
i don't think that the talks blew up
over aid to individuals
it really blew up over aid to cities and
states that have been hurt their budgets
hurt by the virus and
are now facing situations where they're
having to furlough people or lay off
policemen firefighters and teachers
do you see any hope for this coming back
being picked up before the election
i think it's pretty dismal right now as
far as what it looks like
after the negotiations were shut down
the president tweeting that he wanted to
do these individual standalone bills
but he essentially handed a political
weapon to the democrats at least for the
short term
to say look he's not he's not
negotiating anymore
he's stopping this but you know on the
flip side
remember democrats were not coming off
2.4 trillion dollars for a long time
and you mentioned the cities and states
they republicans just wanted a caveat
that said
if you had problems before covid with
your finances
this doesn't qualify for getting relief
and they were trying to get to that
caveat mark meadows is going to be on
the show on special report later
uh and we'll see what he thinks but i
don't think it's possible in 28 days
wow okay so dana mitch mcconnell has
said
speaking to brett bear's point you know
a lot of these states had big pension
liabilities and we're not going to bail
them out so let the states go bankrupt
if that's what it is
but it's not just a blue state problem
if you think of it in purely political
terms
you know their red states uh florida for
example huge budget holes
why wouldn't the president want to do
something right now
i think that the president does want to
do something right now and i think that
he realizes that he absolutely needs to
do something right now even though i
think last night was a little bit of a
ploy um to
perhaps get nancy pelosi to back off of
her position now she's been the one
that has delayed this for a long time
when it comes to many of those states
they are
sitting on a ton of money that was
passed in the original cares act
billions of dollars and i think the
republicans were correct to say
until you can show that you've already
spent those funds why would we give you
additional money we should save that
money for people who actually need it
maybe schools or airlines
and nancy pelosi has held up this bill
for a long time she recently had said
that not getting a bill done was
preferable to her than to
not getting any money out the door was
preferable for her if she didn't get
this comprehensive bill i talked about
yesterday
there's lots of things in there that
people wouldn't like the end of
voter id laws for example nationalizing
ballot harvesting
stimulus payments to illegal immigrants
things that you would think
would be able to be stripped out and in
fact house
democrats who are more moderate voted
against that position and told nancy
pelosi like
that is unacceptable we don't need to
have that in this bill so it's a little
bit
galling that all of a sudden she's
calling for urgency for these things
because she is
the one that has held it up for several
months so jesse the other side of that
coming from nancy pelosi is they the
house under nancy pelosi just
last week passed a 200 trillion dollar
bill and tried to get
not 200 trillion he didn't not too
2.2 2.2 sorry 2.2 trillion breitbart
just helped me out
but now now you get people like senator
susan
collins and even some of the
conservatives in the house saying this
is a big mistake for
us as a republican party to wait we got
to act now the american people want
action on this economic aid now
yeah they do so let's get it out you can
do it piecemeal but you don't have to
have it be a slush fund for failed blue
states juan
only in washington can saying 2.2
trillion dollars is too much
get you accused of being high on drugs i
mean we've already spent
3.6 trillion come on what are we talking
about
i don't want to bore you guys with the
numbers but nancy's asking for
35 times more money than what the blue
states have lost so far in the corona
virus
we're talking a quarter trillion to
teachers unions
a half a trillion to blue states with no
strings attached
you give that to de blasio and cuomo you
know it just becomes a bailout slush
fund that they can skim off and buy
votes with
i mean seriously but to be honest with
you
the numbers are so big it makes people's
eyes glaze over the media sides with the
democrats
and republicans usually cave so we'll
see what happens
so greg i saved the toughest question
for you because the federal chairman
jerome
powell he said you know what err on the
side
of too much money he said the economy
needs
a massive package at this point to avoid
collapse
what does greg say i say everything that
jesse just said
answers that question but what's up
what's obvious i mean
it's it's a fact this is a massive
package and i'm an expert on massive
packages
what's obvious to the what's obvious to
the media
and then and they're pretending this
isn't true nancy
orchestrated this so trump would veto it
so out of the quarter corner of their ma
of her mouth she's saying we can't
politicize the virus and on the other
corner she's politicizing the
the virus if the republicans had pulled
something like that you know what we'd
be called
murderers that we're letting people die
this bill was
impossible to pass and intended to fail
because the democrats are more willing
to let people die than help trump let me
repeat that because this is what they
they always like to say people have
blood on their hands the democrats are
more willing to let people
die than help trump they could get this
money out by stripping this stuff out of
the package
but they won't do it because they want
to hurt trump
that's their priority it's sad but i'm
just using their vernacular that they've
used on republicans
for the past four uh 40 years
hey greg i wanted to follow up you know
really i saw in the papers today
that that the white house aides and
everybody was saying you know these
steroids
they do cause you to have some you know
mental blips sometimes and people are
worried about the present now
some people might say hey that's a slur
against the president of the united
states but
some of his own aides and people who are
doctors are saying no that steroids can
really change the way you think and act
well you know what i think everything is
uh
donald trump has talked about uh joe
biden
being on meds so all's fair in love and
war i mean i mean
look uh if he said you know he said that
about joe they could say that about
donald trump
i hardly think he cares that that's
being said um but you know
you take one trump's blown up talks
sober without steroids that's true this
could be any different
hey wait wait jesse you're on his side
you're not supposed to say that
well it's true he's blown up talks every
year with nancy
are not the issue yeah it's not steroids
all right thanks guys